[Música]
a
escala en parís
palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 en esta edición les invitamos a
adentrarnos en el fascinante mundo de la
genética de los humanos de dónde venimos
a dónde vamos a estas preguntas responde
a través del estudio de los genes el
científico
franco-español luis quintana murci
muchísimas gracias luis por estar con
nosotros vernos buenos de test genetista
dirige la unidad de genética evolutiva
humana en el instituto pasteur de parís
y acaba de publicar este libro el pueblo
de los humanos en la editorial odile
jacob fruto de 25 años de investigación
y en este libro dan muchas respuestas a
una pregunta que nos hacemos todos de
dónde venimos pues venimos de áfrica y
es lo que explicó en este libro como el
estudio de nuestros genes del adn de las
diferencias de genomas que hay entre
individuos y poblaciones humanas como a
través de ese estudio podemos
reconstruir la historia de los humanos
donde nacimos cuáles fue nuestras
y cómo nos adaptamos a los diferentes
ambientes que hemos encontrado y cómo es
posible secuenciar genomas enteros de
una persona que vivió hace miles y miles
de años y de la que sólo se ha
encontrado un trocito de hueso o un
diente es fascinante no es fascinante y
es una disciplina relativamente nueva se
llama la paleogenética y a partir de
huesos podemos extraer el adn de esos
huesos aunque sea de 30 a 40 mil años y
después secuenciar el genoma que
encontramos en ese adn
sabemos que hubo mestizaje entre sapiens
que como decía vienen de áfrica y van a
europa de neandertales que eran los que
estaban en europa y también de denisova
y en asia pudo haber otras formas de
humanos y que por el momento no
conocemos en genética se puede ver eso
se puede ver algún gen que no
corresponde a ninguna a ningún pueblo de
humanos que conocemos hasta ahora si
esto es una pregunta muy interesante
hay algunos estudios que muestran que
sabemos hoy que los europeos y los
asiáticos tenemos alrededor 2 por ciento
de nuestro genoma que viene de
neandertal algunos asiáticos también
tienen 23 por ciento de su genoma que
viene del hombre de denisova que vivían
en asia pero un
gran descubrimiento que se ha hecho en
los últimos años ha sido ver que los
africanos también tienen en su genoma
una parte de su genoma que viene de otra
forma humana pero que aún no se ha
descubierto y eso lo hemos descubierto
solo y únicamente gracias a los estudios
genéticos en por qué es tan importante
justamente la genética para saber
quiénes somos porque la genética a
diferencia de la arqueología y la
paleontología
no se basa en vamos a buscar allí y
vamos a ver si encontramos huesos de
alguien la genética nos deja la
oportunidad nos da la oportunidad de
estudiar nuestro genoma entero y
comparando los genomas de diferentes
poblaciones humanas podemos
completamente reconstruir
la historia de nuestra especie ya que
ahí están todas las huellas de miles y
miles de años de evolución las huellas
de nuestras migraciones las huellas de
cómo nos hemos adaptado al frío a los
patógenos las huellas de cómo nos hemos
mezclado con otras especies o
simplemente entre diferentes poblaciones
humanas justamente el encuentro del homo
sapiens con el hombre de neandertal en
europa va a ser determinante para que el
hombre pueda adaptarse no solo a las
condiciones climáticas también a virus y
bacterias de qué manera se adapta hombre
uno tiene que pensar que cuando nuestros
ancestros salieron de áfrica llegaron a
europa hace unos 60 mil años y en europa
encuentran un ambiente completamente
diferente frío y otras enfermedades
infecciosas una de las cosas que mi
laboratorio ha demostrado es que gracias
a ese primer mestizaje entre los sapiens
y el hombre de neandertal que vivía en
europa y que hacía trescientos mil años
que vivió en europa y por definición
estaba adaptado gracias a ese mestizaje
sapiens adquirieron mutaciones que les
permitieron de mejor sobrevivir a las
enfermedades infecciosas sobre todo las
enfermedades infecciosas causadas por
virus arn como el virus de la gripe o
incluso el commit 19 en seguida
hablaremos de esa relación que hay con
la genética podemos decir que bueno
gracias a ese mestizaje entonces estamos
aquí si una de las cosas que desarrollo
mucho en este libro es como el mestizaje
que sea con otras formas humanas como
los neandertales o simplemente entre
poblaciones humanas modernas nosotros ha
sido un facilitador una ha dado una
aceleración a la adaptación de nuestra
especie al ambiente el mestizaje nos ha
permitido de mejor sobrevivir hay muchos
datos sorprendentes en este libro el
pueblo de los humanos
la adaptación a condiciones extremas
puede cambiarnos genéticamente
y un ejemplo muy sorprendente es el qué
comenta en el libro un pueblo de
indonesia que es capaz de aguantar bajo
el agua trece minutos explíquenos
nosotros podemos aguantar bajo el agua
máximo un uno o dos minutos este pueblo
pasa 60% del día a pescar a hacer pesca
submarina
entonces este pueblo que se llaman los
bajau han adquirido una mutación
genética que hace que pueden pasar mucho
más tiempo en apnea es decir
sigue sin respirar y gracias a esta
mutación genética pueden pasar 13
minutos bajo el agua un ejemplo inédito
de adaptación extrema y cuánto tiempo
lleva que los genes se adapten son
cuestiones de miles de años son
cuestiones de miles de años porque no
nos olvidemos que al principio para que
un gen se adapte tiene que aparecer una
mutación y una mutación aparece en un
individuo y para que esta mutación pase
a la población son miles de años
cuando los sabios llegan a europa tienen
que adaptarse al frío lo comentábamos a
la falta de sol como se traduce eso en
la evolución humana como eran los
primeros europeos pues los primeros
europeos hoy se sabe que gracias a los
estudios de genética y de paleo genética
que tenían la piel oscura pero los ojos
azules es decir los ojos azules llegaron
primero que la piel clara y después
empezaron a perder la pigmentación de la
piel porque
necesitaban perderla porque la vitamina
d se sintetiza gracias al sol y en
latitudes en las que vivimos en las que
hay mucho menos sol que en áfrica
necesitamos perder la pigmentación de la
piel y es por esto que hoy tenemos la
pigmentación clara su especialidad es el
estudio de la diversidad del genoma a
través de las poblaciones humanas y su
relación con las enfermedades
infecciosas en los genes se lee la
huella genética de los virus y las
bacterias que han contribuido a esas
mutaciones genéticas se lee se puede
leer se ve absolutamente esto es una de
las especialidades de mi laboratorio
aquí en el instituto
es leer en nuestro genoma cuáles han
sido los patógenos que han dejado y
huellas en nuestro genoma y dónde han
dejado huellas porque eso quiere decir
que se han dejado huellas en genes en
especial que esos genes son los más
importantes para nosotros para poder
resistir a las enfermedades en el libro
hay un capítulo dedicado al coronavirus
y según explica la herencia de
neandertal nos hace más vulnerables al
cob y 19 es decir la gente que tiene más
porcentaje de neandertal
tienen más chances de acabar en el
hospital no que los que no tienen
explíquenos porque es un poco más
complicado es decir 16 por ciento de los
europeos tenemos una serie de mutaciones
neandertales que aumentan de 60 por
ciento el hecho de estar de desarrollar
un qubit severo pero no todo es tan
simple porque después 30 por ciento de
otros europeos tenemos otras mutaciones
de neandertal que en ese caso nos
protege y disminuyen de 22% las chances
de desarrollar un hobbit severo entonces
la herencia neandertal de nuestra genoma
es un poco doble o sea que es un poco o
sea nos puede beneficiar y también nos
puede perjudicar ante los los virus
es una pregunta que usted me dirá si se
puede contestar o no esto explicaría en
parte porque en los países africanos la
tasa de mortalidad por el coi 19 es
menor que en el resto del mundo y yo he
buscado un ejemplo que por población me
parecía interesante no nigeria 200
millones de habitantes ha habido 3100
muertos méxico con 130 millones de
habitantes ha habido al menos 300.000
fallecidos no se se puede establecer una
relación con él
los genes con la parte me under call no
por el momento con los genes estamos en
ello la comunidad científica aún
conocemos relativamente poco como la
genética aumenta nuestras chances de
desarrollar un coach severo pero no
somos sólo una un envoltorio de genes en
áfrica y otras cosas que pueden explicar
esto como un seguimiento epidemia en
premio lógico menos bueno y también el
hecho que hace mucho más calor y como
sabemos el calor es el mayor enemigo de
este virus y de qué manera el kobe 19
puede transformar nuestra genética es
decir el humano dentro de un tiempo se
habrá modificado genéticamente para no
ser vulnerable a la coidh 19 para eso
nos tendríamos que ver y tendríamos que
hacer otra entrevista de radio dentro de
tres mil o cuatro mil años
bueno y ya nos queda ya poquito tiempo
de qué manera todos estos
descubrimientos sobre nuestros genes
pueden contribuir a que nuestro futuro
sea mejor a que se construyan personas
genéticamente más mejores no casi
perfectas vamos hacia un hombre o una
mujer genéticamente resistente a todo no
lo creo que vamos hacia un hombre una
mujer resistente a todo porque
si hay algo que no controlamos son los
cambios de ambiente los cambios de tipo
de vida la llegada de otra enfermedades
hacia lo que sí vamos es que el
conocimiento genético de nuestros
genomas entre diferentes individuos o
poblaciones va a ayudar a que podamos
desarrollar lo que se llama una medicina
de precisión una medicina más
personalizada que utilizará nuestra
genética pero también nuestro modo de
vida lo que comemos todos esos microbios
que viven con nosotros para adaptar más
los tratamientos médicos a cada persona
y evitar efectos secundarios necesitan
bastantes medios financieros para poder
desarrollar ese tipo de medicina
exactamente pero creo que no estamos
lejos dentro de unos 10 años vamos a
empezar a ver la llegada de la medicina
personalizada bueno pues este libro la
web de yunnan está de momento en francés
el pueblo de los humanos en la editorial
odile jacob y yo quería preguntarle para
cuando este libro en español porque
seguramente nuestros oyentes y
telespectadores quieren saber si lo
pueden leer en español pues sí estamos
en ello y dentro de unos meses estará
disponible en español
igual no tendrá el mismo título pero
estoy muy contento que se traduzca en
español porque el los lectores
hispanoparlantes les va a gustar mucho
este libro pues muchísimas gracias luis
quintana murci por haber estado con
nosotros hace somos otros y muchísimas
gracias a todos ustedes por habernos
acompañado ya saben que nos pueden
seguir también por internet en rf y
mundo.com bien france24 puntocom hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]